success is like 85 90% who your dad is
now. I'm sorry to say that, but that's
the truth. The reason I want people to
know that is not because I want them to
give up and not work hard, but because
the reality is if you come from a poor
background, it is very, very difficult
to even be able to buy a home and afford
a family. And I want people to know that
because I want young men to go out
there, work their hardest and recognize
that if they are able to buy a house and
support a family from a poor ordinary
background, they are doing really well.
They are doing really really really
well. Because I think this message that
tells young people you are what you
make, you you get out what you put in
and then gives all the money and all the
wealth to people from rich families who
then go and post it on Instagram is
making our young men feel like absolute.
It's making a young men feel like and
we're lying to them. Listen, the truth
is we've kind of broken society now. And
if you come from a poor background, it's
almost impossible for you to ever be
rich. But it is possible for you to have
a family, protect that family, support
that family, and live a dignified life
where you are proud of yourself and what
you achieve. So what I want young people
to realize is yes, social mobility has
been destroyed. And yes, if you are from
a poor background, that makes it maybe
impossible for you to get rich, but that
doesn't mean your life is over. There
are important things that you can
achieve that you can do for yourself and
your family and for the people you care